hello hello
everyone
hear me okay
everyone hear me okay
hey darling Zoo
hey Sammy hey Jeff
hey subscribe to Lucky
how's everyone doing
Hey Big E slime
hey Jen's Mertens
hey Tommy
hey Jerry
hey Dave I don't know how to say that
name Davey Vaughn
sorry uh Davone
hey Michael hi Isaiah
okay so I've started the second trial
already
um and this is kind of towards the end
so I think I'm about to fight the boss
so I thought I'd pop on for this part of
the the trial because it's the most
exciting I think
hey Ricky
is anyone still waiting for the game
I'm assuming most people have beaten the
game already
what do you guys think of the fit
one to ten
yeah the the last part of the trial that
I just did was quite confusing it took
me a little while
10 out of 10 thank you
yeah it's not bad
I think I need to change the mask though
it doesn't doesn't fit with everything
Maybe
just one of those
kind of like these
bit tight around the waist yeah
you have the same armor Brian
okay let's go fight this this boss then
shall we
just got Cruise here oh cool
thank you
too easy
foreign
this boss
how does everyone like the game if you
had to give the game a score what would
you give it
Secrets hidden in sand first time in a
live stream hello HP Theory welcome
I don't do them a lot but they're coming
at increasing frequency
thanks for the Super Chat
I might
use Expelliarmus
is a good idea I think
watching the fourth movie Ten nine out
of 10 10 out of 10. 8.7
why isn't it a 10 what would you guys
improve
that's my question now
is the way I came I don't know
no it's not
save
add animagus yeah
um I give it a nine I think
about a night like it's close to perfect
it's just missing a few things like I
think it needs to be longer they need to
extend the game but
I can't really complain otherwise
right remind me to use my ancient Magics
I always forget to use it
revelio
oh
what do we have here
maybe a funkier hat I don't know the
Fedora is pretty good isn't it
Roca what sort of story content do you
think DLCs will add everyone yeah what
do you guys think
it's a good question
I'd like to see uh more of the schools
around the world
um I'd like to see Diagon Alley that
would be massive
excuse me for a moment guys
oh
maybe back to this side
foreign
too easy guys
too easy
even Source they're going to stream
together soon yeah I'd like to
places
for the odds
oh my goodness
ouch okay
almost happened
here we go
not bad
not too bad
Rebellion
yeah I know I have to use a certain
color spell
yeah I know that lucky
the the first boss was like that in the
first straw
this one was actually easier than the
other ones I think
all right let's have a look
this is cool
look at this my mind
yeah so what
expansions would you guys like I think I
missed it did you guys already answer
that
say I'm curious to hear Visa does
travels
please have a seat
Isadora
I didn't play for about a week to hear
we're ready
I've something to show you
father
these are my colleagues from Hogwarts
yippee Arena yeah
cool
father hasn't spoken since my brother
died
on my travels I confirmed that which
I've always believed
that we have the power to take away pain
what's all this then
the Dora
oh my
what have you done
I took his pain one of those memories
this is Uncharted magic is Adora
you can only see what has been sealed in
the jar and we do not know what power
that may hold
but the traces of that magic are
different from what I've seen before
looked like memories from the pensive
but I don't think that's what it was
she said pain
is it painful memories or is it
something else if you know the answer
don't answer me off I don't
uh give me the answer
yeah I feel like the Forbidden Forest
was a little bit flat in this game
that's one complaint I have you're back
like I like it one piece no less this
doesn't quite seem
as abundant as I always it is like to
see you again
Professor Rookwood told me about what
happened at Rookwood Castle
in light of the dire circumstances in
which we find ourselves it is most
fortunate that someone so competent is
following this path thank you Professor
I shall keep the second artifacts safe
as you've advised good are you ready to
move on
I'm ready for whatever comes next in
that case introductions are annoying
yeah it does that's true allow me to
introduce former Hogwarts headmistress
Neve Fitzgerald
Eve
Shane Cannon I've done it how do you do
video on the head Mistresses
to learn that a student had been
completing the trials
I've always believed Hogwarts students
capable of anything they set their minds
to thank you Professor I don't know if
she's in my face pleasure to meet you as
well I am certain that you are more than
capable of completing my trial however I
must first
shall I say prepare the location of your
next you guys like the stream please
give it a like and trust your judgment
Professor Fitzgerald you should know
better than anyone how to manage the
inconvenience of well
of Inglorious and exasperating
Headmaster
indeed I should I shall confirm that
everything is in order immediately
of course Co-op here Fitzgerald needs
some time to clear the way forward until
then it's the third trial magic if you
learn more about ran Rock and Victor
rookwood's activities in the meantime
the only thing I hate doing is sneaking
around very well professor
I know I know continue to hone my magic
you do learn quickly hopefully you will
soon hear from school Nazis yeah they
should learn how he fared with the
helmet you retrieved well done today as
always we shall speak again soon
that was cool
I like that
[Music]
wagadu ilvermorny
these are all other Wizarding schools
[Music]
I have mail
who's still waiting for the game on
other platforms
any of you guys
so many quests
foreign
is this a fun Quest has anyone done this
waiting for Xbox One okay yeah
this is where I have to go
Defender
I don't think I have that yet upper
hogsfield
oh once you have completed the tasks
I've set forth
oh I want Bombardier that's for sure
these rocks have seen better days
what's this is this the cave
thank you
this must be Top This cave I suppose I
should head inside
let's have a look shall we
do I need uh lumos probably
missed your quota by three files you
know what that means it means my loyal
customers will be missing their bottles
of Sheamus's shrinking solution because
if you're a foolish mistake you'll be
given no food for a week I also expect
you to punish yourself accordingly when
I return for the next shipment I'd best
see bloodied bandages instead of your
usual idiotic grin if you do not meet
your next quota plus five extra files
you will lose more than your food
privileges okay tobs's Master is awful
tops
Deke sent me
are you in here
too easy
says if tops was there so it's hard
we must have headed deeper into the cave
this is quite a cave
good freedom
Rebellion
yeah I've got to do more side quests I'm
lacking
Rebellion
oh what was that
good Franco
what did I just get hit with
hey Ellie
eight legs
oh that's what I blew up okay I get it
now
oh that was close
uh oh
don't like this
oh my goodness I can't see anything
thank you
hey true science and welcome back
yeah sorry I'm so inconsistent with the
streams I mean I guess I did go from no
streams in four years to a reasonable
amount
I haven't given up on them
Roca thanks for tuning in
that didn't sound particularly
reassuring
uh I have some cool spells I have uh
crucio
and then we're gonna get bombardo meet
me in the undercroft I found something
and we're gonna do that Quest next
with uh Sebastian because I think that's
an unforgivable curse isn't it
thank you thank you
hey Travis thank you thank you
I appreciate that
oh my goodness who is this handsome
fellow
good finger
tough my goodness
are these tougher than the normal
spiders
they were tough that wasn't too easy
all right
how to get crucio
um I did one of the side quests with
Sebastian
and ominous as well
that was like a few levels ago
foreign
this looks like the right way
oh no I have a feeling that book review
love the content got to go hope you keep
it up
thanks for watching man
this is uh just to show you true sighted
what do you think
Rebellion
oh did tobs die
pool tops
left here alone that's sad
my goodness so grim
do I have to find my way out of the cave
can I go this way
well maybe yeah
it looks like it
that tape looks familiar it seems I'm
back at the entrance to the cave
welcome to the Stream
welcome welcome
uh digs it in the room of requirement
right
foreign
ly getting a bit better at navigating
the maps and the
the flu powder and things I was really
bad at it before and I just ended up
running everywhere
I'm gonna do the Sebastian Quest next I
think that'll be fun
but first
no
how do I interact with this
foreign
Jay Stratford or Octavian unforgettables
her last resort yeah that's true they
should be
thanks for the supercar
school uniform
mute goggles
okay
oh I like that
who's my favorite Harry Potter character
um maybe Dumbledore
oh whoa both of these increased damage
with confringa
yeah I wish you could just jump straight
to the quest as well that would make
things easier wouldn't it
I'm back from the cave dick wonderful
Deke hopes you gave digs best to tobs
I'm sorry to tell you this dick
tobs is gone
it seems I didn't play Fable with the
spiders in the end who am I
dick was afraid of this I like
Dumbledore I like snakes I kind of like
the gray characters because I would say
that Dumbledore is one shared the same
way when he in a lot of ways died we
were separated he's no goody too I've
always wish tobs had been sent to
Hogwarts too
feels lucky to serve such kind witches
and wizards like you they will miss his
friend dearly so it looks like soon I'll
be learning bombarded with a heavy heart
it's time to move it's wise to move on
there's nothing to be done now
indeed understands imagine you find
someone give you some time alone dead
friend and then you just go it's time to
move on
the first time you tell them
so insensitive
[Music]
any new Theory videos coming out
um yeah I've got what's coming up next
oh it's not a theory but the next video
will be looking at some of the portraits
around Hogwarts and just identifying
them giving them giving a little bit of
History
that'll probably be a series
um and then I also have a video
talking about why sacrificial protection
isn't used more often
and I also have a video where I
calculate
the exact figure for the amount of gold
in Harry's Vault so those are the next
couple
but there's always lots on the go
quests
you like the famous slytherins one cool
thank you
foreign
managed to make a stream
uh where am I going
oh wow all the way up here
now that I've kind of
broken through that initial anxiety of
making live streams I'll probably do
them more often
which I have been doing
I'd like to do some
you know apart from playing this game as
well
Rebellion
can you make a video on why didn't Harry
die in The Forbidden Forest I just made
that recently
you can uh you can see it on the chat it
was this week a week a week ago
hey Martin
just for context Octavian killed someone
later
thanks for the Super Chat look at that
I'm spoiled
I don't trust ran Rock
what's everyone's favorite
unforgivable curse
here you go swing
all right
he told me what the two
oh this isn't the quest that I wanted to
do is it
what's this one
complete totally didn't mean to do this
one but I mean I guess I'll do it
I'm already here right
High Wings fine I'm keeping an eye on
her good what's that you said you had
news about the boat it did
[Music]
it did somewhat but at the moment I'm
more concerned about what else you heard
the poachers are up to fair enough
does the name horntow Hall mean any I'm
afraid not Hotel Hall what is it the
poacher's best kept secret apparently my
day's been good ghosting how are you
came up twice two scripts for the
channel today undoubtedly
[Music]
keeping things from Grand aren't we I
normally tell her she can keep things
from Grand she might be my best friend
should you keep things from Grand
everyone comments how I feel about the
poachers
he worries I'll do something whatever
gave her them
this way
kind of don't want to be doing this
Quest but it's too late
what
you can you keep things from Grand
Isaiah
oh
an entire Castle to Rome yet you choose
to wander here
please we don't want any trouble we're
simply passing through
do you take us for fools that we do not
notice more and more of your kind around
here in League with the poachers
we aren't involved with them if anything
we want to see them stopped
Our Kind is swiftly losing patience with
the poachers and those they work with
should I uh
should I pull one of these on the center
of wizard kind and the poachers aren't
helping matters but why would he think
that we had anything with my character's
blood status I did notice the poachers a
few villages
he was a pure blood until recently and
then muggle blood
got into this
lineage
what's yours
sort of like the Dumbledore's who
you know I mean Albus was a half blood
but not generationally
is that a lot of Beast to be more
aggressive than usual lately
I've noticed that too can I turn the
game volume up yeah I can turn it up a
little bit uh hold on
I'm just gonna fiddle with it let me
know if it's too quiet too loud
okay so it's a minus 17.
let me know how this uh game volume is I
just reduced it or sorry increased it
bloodless yeah odd what is it
entirely sure what's your uh blood
status
and thank you again for the Super Chat
still smoking
and they can't have been gone wrong
that's good okay cool
this is Goblin metal
the first time I ever streamed this game
I got I should tell copyright Pelt
um poor be struck
I think it's because the game volume is
too high any
who's my favorite Weasley
um probably Ron
not so much in the films
because they kind of
I don't know they didn't accurately
portray his character but probably Ron
enjoy this next mission it's one of my
favorites I had to play the game two
times because of an unfortunate saving
error but this Quest stands out as one
of my favorites oh okay cool what was
the unfortunate saving error poachers
were here also I found Goblin armor
let's keep searching but that doesn't
sound carefully
no
I don't have a good feeling about this
no it's fine I think the volume should
be okay
if uh the stream gets taken down and
I'll just kick things back up with a
reduced volume look down there
no creatures though so what are they
doing out here
take a closer look
they won't be happy to see us
definitely not using destinations
hard to say from up here
let's get a better lay of the land
absolutely not hiding no chance
yeah
I haven't a clue
good fingers
is that it
is you'd think they were guarding the
minister for magic himself what is going
on here only one way to find out
Rebellion
what
yeah they kind of dumbed down Ron I
mustn't do all your books after not
reading them for a while remembering
less of a no fears in the books yeah it
was much more charismatic in the books
that's for sure one of the most dumbed
down characters I would say Ginny as
well
Jay Stratford two pound Super Chat
retracted I don't know what that was but
thank you
you are
supporting me very much thank you thank
you
my voice thank you
I assume that's a compliment
played about 80 hours but I manually
saved it 25 so I had to go back really
far oh my goodness that's quite a long
way
yeah Ron was not as dumb in in the books
and um I don't know you just had more
life to him I I still liked Ron in the
films but
uh comparatively you know he was worse
oh my goodness
forever
who is uh everyone's favorite reason
[Applause]
but to all the families
it's a dragon fighting ring I know when
sorry one second it may make sense now
and secrecy no wonder the poachers were
in hogsmeade so how could they possibly
there must be more dragons here
we should take advantage of most guys
being fighting
so yeah in the in the books uh sorry in
the films when Harry would ask questions
about the Wizarding World Hermione would
be the one to answer but in the books it
was more commonly run which makes more
sense given that Hermione didn't find
out about the Wizarding World until
recently and Ron had lived in it his
whole life
everyone is a pure blood but others take
different paths
I don't know what you mean by that Jay
do I have to use the disillusionment
here
rather not
Rebellion
oh all of your characters okay that
makes sense
I thought you meant everyone
so you have characters from every house
thank you
what are we doing
what are we what's going on
[Applause]
what am I good
this one opened
how do I get in here guys
Jay is spreading the abundance
have you ever known family is either of
your brothers come out to our way of
thinking where they join us ah they say
we go too far the violence isn't gonna
get us what we want
[Music]
I'm not gonna sneak around
no way
uh yeah you can learn all of the
unforgivable curses
apparently I mean I don't have them all
yet but I think
boy mate
10 super chat thank you very much
Hermione film doesn't make sense why
does she has more knowledge on The
Wizarding World than a pure blood wizard
I know it doesn't make sense
but she's a no-it-all but he's lived in
it his whole life obviously
[Applause]
[Music]
speak to Poppy what does she want
did you hear those goblins Round Rock on
the poachers must be working together
what is going on behind you what's going
on
oh
they must have always captured her she's
putting up quite a fight that's a fair
one though I thought when I cleaned up
like that
shall we
Rock Jay
thanks again
I appreciate these super chats
Dragon egg
and I've always said Hebrews
do you guys say he brilliant or
hebridian
also poppy sounds like Hermione
aloha
we made I love your work thank you so
much for sharing light on Harry Potter
law and for helping everyone to
understand every nook and cranny of the
Canon
thank you for watching guys I mean
honestly this is my my dream all right I
have the egg you guys make it possible
thank you by watching I'm so surprised
it's very generous Super Chat
digging the outfit armor and that hat is
a fun combo absolutely
don't go wrong
he pulled the entire Harry Potter fan
base on their favorite character who do
you think would be first uh oh tough
question I'd say it would be like
between
Draco because Dragon
you know devout fan base
um
everyone loves Sirius but I think his
favorite
wouldn't be Hermione I don't think
everything
okay
so we've got probably serious I think
Snape
after Harry Potter films I never see a
film from create the books it always
change the characters to the work
poppy is the Hermione of this world
trust what she says
she sounds like
you're the one-way looking forward
so many of them
tonight
my goodness that was a lot
um I imagine poppy doing an elf rights
thing in Hogwarts Legacy too yeah I
think just that spot on
uh oy mate I've always wondered that if
Flitwick we're gonna go and Snape was a
duel Voldemort simultaneously out of
three rounds who would come out on top
um I think I think they might come out
on top honestly it's a good uh
it's a good subject to explore though I
don't know I'd have to look into it a
bit deeper to give you a proper answer
but I think
I think just because Snape is there and
he's arguably you know one of the top
five powerful wizards of the time uh
they'd start a chance
potato hey HP theory was in a stream a
couple weeks back how are you I'm good
how are you doing I'm level 32 and I
finish I just need to be 34 to do the
house cut but I have like nothing left
to make it higher I guess just go kill
random things I don't know does anyone
anyone have advice for David
sleepy your voice is very quiet is it
still quiet
guys
also thank you Jay annoy mate for the
for the other Super Chat
watch out for the flame spurts yeah well
done thank you
do you think watching the Fantastic
Beasts films are worth watching just
finished a Harry Potter marathon
yeah I think I think they're worth
watching I mean it's in the same realm
they're not as good so don't go into
them expecting Harry Potter but um
I enjoy them
you can't have uh
how do I do this
back here
that took a few tries didn't it
especially since McGonagall was somewhat
holding around again this may have been
a bad idea
oh my God
cool
the secrets of Dumbledore was my
favorite of those films
the first one was my least favorite
Merlin Trump
spoiling
I haven't beat the game yet
this way
this was a good Quest I'm glad I did it
do I personally regard cursed child as
Canon or do you prefer it to stay in its
room making the noise pretending it does
not exist
um yeah it's not canon I mean I don't
completely disregard it and if I discuss
topics that
skirt on cursed child Cannon I'll
mention that I don't think she doesn't
think they need to be treated she
wouldn't have left without it what now
she didn't exactly leave us a calling
card I
know
nothing about this day was expected not
the goblins and definitely not the
fighting ring the last thing I planned
on was a dragon egg and the poacher saw
it we mate asked earlier who would win
in a duel between Flitwick McGonagall
and Snape versus Voldemort what do you
guys think
helping ourselves standing here let's
get to safety we can sort this out later
you're right
pray and
be careful won't you I shall see you
back at the castle
[Music]
me too
look at me
Rebellion
it's time you learned the transformation
smell after you've completed the
required tasks which I'm certain will
prove useful in finishing your Field
Guide attend my class to learn the new
yeah I think I think the trio would win
too
I've got to drop some stuff I have too
much stuff
I should sell some stuff actually
afterwards we will discuss your progress
thus far in the term
okay I'm gonna go
to a shop and sell some things and then
I'm going to do the Sebastian Quest
has there ever been a long-standing
Wizarding war against Muggles
um
I wouldn't really call it a war
I think in the medieval period and
before the medieval period
uh they were kind of aware of each
other's existence
and they were witch hunts and things
like that so wizard kind of kept to
themselves but there definitely was a
time of conflict
and because the Muggles wouldn't back
down that's why the Wizarding Community
had to kind of fall into the Shadows
I've done some videos on this I'm not
totally refreshed on the topic but
um if you go to my channel you should be
able to find something
but I don't think there was any massive
war or anything like that
and I know that some Wizards
participated in the Muggle Wars like
World War II for example even though
they were told not to
I think the best battle would have been
Dumbledore versus Snape nah Dumbledore
was too powerful for Snape Snape's top
five for me but I think
Dumbledore is number one
sell not drop yeah
okay let's go to a shop
let's go to a shop what is this
this will do
I hope that answers your question my
mate thank you again for the Super Chat
if you're stuck at level uh
32 you just have to run around and pet
all the cats
why why did I come here I'm not even
sure why I did this
I want to go to a shop
I'm so bad at navigating oh my goodness
foreign
stressful
can I not just
travel straight to hogsmeade
okay hold on let me there's too much
going on in the chat let me have a look
oh change the hogsmeade map ah yes of
course okay I'll do that first and then
I'll have a look at the chat
uh
um
that's what I wanted
the
with the Salem witch trials in real life
connected to the Wizarding World where
the witches of 100 execute actual
witches like we've seen Harry Potter
does the Wizarding World have religion
so as far as they know within Harry
Potter Canon the Salem Witch Trials did
happen
um and Muggles did get it wrong some of
the time and there were Muggles that
were accused of being witches that were
burned and uh The Wizarding World does
have religion
but if you want more extensive answer
I've actually done a video on it
recently I would advise you to watch
that one just for a more comprehensive
answer
but uh thank you again for the Super
Chat
are the Dragon Balls just shenron's
horcruxes I guess that kind of makes
sense
sell all the things absolutely
now Muggles mess everything up
what are we looking for today
nice doing business with you
oh this looks good
mate do I have something better than
this
surprising
I have to be up for a rehearsal in a few
hours good stream so good night good
night thanks for joining
oh yes Hassam my talent points
absolutely
cool I still have a few
I like to look at this
silent mask
thanks for stopping by hope to see you
again
what mask did I switch to
oh confringo
okay so I will sell it
genie versus panzy Parkinson yep be good
one what are we looking for today
keep this one
thanks for stopping by hope to see you
again sorry to be a pest for asking so
many questions but is this channel
related to Star Wars Theory yeah so
um ice that's not you're not a past uh
it's fine to ask questions
um yeah he started the Channel with me
so we know each other in real life
uh he had Star Wars Theory
um and one day we came together and made
this channel
so he was uh voicing things kind of in
the beginning
um but just over time dropped off so he
could focus on Star Wars Theory more and
then I kind of took the reins
but for the first uh the channel has
been around for four years and the first
like year of the channel he was quite
involved
but he's still uh he's still a part of
the channel
t-bris gaming hello I'm not fairy though
you can't call me Theory that's his
that's his moniker
deep YouTuber Loria exactly
as the title tales of the Wizarding
World Is it good
what are you uh referring to Jay
have I messed with changing the look of
my outfit like keeping the steps but
changing the look oh yeah this is um
an intentional look so this is not an
accident
are you suggesting I should change the
way that he looks
because I don't know I don't know if it
gets much better than this
true Society degrees
think
foreign
how do I uh deselect
a purple Waypoint
foreign
what's going on here
that purple Waypoint is driving me mad
have I seen Chan Willis comedic take on
HP pretty funny there's a voiceover from
the characters and puts them into famous
scenarios and adds chest Chan Willis
rings a bell let me look
rings a bell
you
[Music]
you I have I've seen uh I've seen some
bits and pieces
she's good
I'm hoping she may be easier on me if
you are there
can we meet to the three Broomsticks May
finally be safe since We rescued the
dragon from horntail Hall tales of the
Wizarding World as a series yeah it's a
good name you'll never believe what I've
learned
thank you two for the super chats
discover in the spell book we found in
the scriptorium Salazar Slytherin
Spellbook was a little difficult to
interpret but fascinating evidently he
encouraged teaching dark magic at
Hogwarts
neither the imperious curse nor the
killing curse was unforgivable during
his time he believed students should be
prepared to use dark magic do you guys
think that students should be taught
magic that's why we had to use Cruise
show to gain access to the scriptorium
he didn't want his knowledge shared with
anyone who was afraid of the power we
talked magic is that a good idea
it was hard to do but casting crucio was
our only option also did you guys say
crucio or cruise ship I also found
something else references to a lost
Relic which from what I can tell grants
the holder the power to reverse dark
magic curses and you think this Relic
might be a precisely I plan to search
for this Relic
I see no reason to involve ominous I'm
glad you agree when I know more I shall
send it out
excruciating
and don't feel sorry for ominous keeping
this to ourselves for now is for his own
good
I'll decide what's for my own good oh
I'm an areas we were just about to get
some air can bring up Joy
you're alive
I'd never swear to give up on finding a
cure for Ram
going to stop do you
I know when not to stop leave this alone
ominous
I'll be on my way
yeah I said crucio but the excruciating
thing is an interesting perspective is
letting this go
if you hover over the existing purple
Waypoint and click exit with deactivate
okay I've got to do that because this is
driving me nuts
where is it
world map
there we go that's it
nice
which do you guys which the which do you
guys think of is the uh most Sinister of
the three unforgivables
ominous Sebastian I know what I heard
you knew I wouldn't agree with this
going after that Relic is not a good
idea Sebastian doesn't even realize it
but he's as irresponsible and Reckless
now as his parents were years ago it's
why they died
I knew his parents died I never heard
what happened Mr and Mrs sallow were
professors
spent nearly every waking moment in the
cellar Library
and those is buried in books Zach thanks
for all the videos you produce always
comes to while going to bed cheers they
heard a suddenly ran downstairs but it
was too late their parents had crumpled
to the floor
a defect with the lamp and the cellar
caused the room to fill with an
undetectable toxin Sebastian and Anne
were helpless they had no magic yet what
a horrible story filled the room that's
why I can't understand Sebastian's
recklessness I've practically lost Anne
I cannot lose Sebastian too
please
those references in the book seem
promising everything to do with Salazar
Slytherin seems promising until it's too
late I hope Sebastian pursues this no
further but if you think he might please
let
it would mean a lot
[Music]
what am I supposed to do now
Mika Skylark hello
favorite Spell aesthetic aesthetically
and for use
um
in the game or in all of Harry Potter
foreign
I think visually
fiend fire is
the most interesting
but I don't I don't think we get that in
this game unfortunately also uh
Firestorm which Dumbledore uses in the
Cave against the inferi
um that's a really cool spell
if I could use those in this game that'd
be amazing maybe in the next one or in
the expansion
what about you
Sinister crucius is the one that
requires the most evil intent
I think so I guess I think crucio may be
the most evil because it literally just
torches people but imperio has a greater
capacity to
do damage I think
all of Harry Potter yeah it'd be it'd be
fiend fire or maybe Firestorm then
or some of that Elemental Magic that
Dumbledore uses in the ministry duel
against uh Voldemort
sorry what am I supposed to do now
what's what's going on
protego diabolica is pretty cool too
yeah
a bit overpowered
was that the whole Quest
what should I do next guys what do I do
only four defensive purposes a good
Ministry
protego diabolica is what Grindelwald
uses in the crimes of Grindelwald and
it's the most advanced form of protego
which is a shield charm so in its most
basic form it's just a basic Shield
charm It reflects some some spells but
the diabolica version
creates a ring of black fire as blue in
the film but it's actually black that
incinerates
enemies that come within it and then
you're all saying
you are also able to wield these these
black Flames like tendrils and fire them
at people and then eventually it turns
into a giant demon
Travis in the book and movies
expelliarma seems to switch between
blasting people back and just disarming
I think it has to do with intent of the
spellcaster or how much magic oomph is
used I think it's a bit of both honestly
it's depends on the context and it
depends on uh who's casting it and how
much they're concentrating on casting it
yeah particular diabolica is the most
powerful curse in Harry Potter by far
they're saving fiend foreign
Travis thank you oy mate for the Super
Chat
foreign
yeah good cool
where do I get a giant purple toad
eater poopoo good night all I'm turning
in for the night good night
sleep well thanks for watching
yeah crimes of uh Grindelwald is good
you guys should watch those films if you
haven't it's worth watching
absolutely it's not Harry Potter but
it's you know it's still magical
and uh the the acting's good
Jude Law was great it's Dumbledore
okay so where do I get this giant purple
toad
get out of here
Naki love the videos man thank you for
taking the time thank you for watching
of course my pleasure
why does Sebastian leave with me
that was strange that he left with me
um okay let's get this towed
shall we
what are you up to now
swampy areas in the Forbidden Forest why
do spells change colors at different
times sometimes Stupify is white other
times it's blue we see wizards use just
a white jet for standard dueling would
that be obilious or maybe stupefy
apologies I meant Superfly alternates
between white and red
um are you referring to the films
because I think a lot of it is just
inconsistency with
the filmmakers unfortunately because I
mean
the books and the films are not on the
same page in that respect at all and I I
did notice in the films that spells
would just change color for no reason
they'll they all should have
one main color for the most part I don't
think they should actually change at any
for any reason
yeah so I think it's like I mean Stupify
is red
but then because of because Expelliarmus
is so prevalent and Expelliarmus is read
in the films I assume they sometimes
they sometimes showed Stupify as white
so that it wouldn't be confused with
Expelliarmus that'd be my best guess
if I remember correctly snaps of
artist's Dumbledore wasn't green either
it's bluish white it was kind of like a
blue I made a video on this
true sighted I think some of why in the
films it changes was intensity
um yeah could be it too
who did it better mads or Depp
um
just different I don't like changing
actors sort of halfway through but I do
think that Mars
more accurately fit the description in
my mind of Grindelwald before they cast
anyone
or mate okay I have to get up at four in
the morning to go to work thanks for
answering my questions have a good night
thanks for stopping by
I appreciate all the questions and super
chats
I hope you have a good night
hopefully I answered everything to your
satisfaction
it's always tough trying to juggle
playing the game and answering questions
I'm not
not so Adept at
um
streaming yet
and multitasking
this looks intriguing
a castle
must have been quite stately in this
time concentrate
knows what he's doing
yourself
oh come on
I honestly wish more battles were like
the double to hold you fight in the
ministry in the fifth rather than one
Glazer tank absolutely I agree
it was uh lacking in that department
I'm doing just fine okay thank you thank
you thank you
doing great bro love watching you thanks
um is it sending me here to do the
giant purple toad Quest or is it sending
me here to do something else
is this where the toads are or is this
where the just where the duracools are
no need to be difficult I mean you know
home
oh my goodness
what is this place
why am I
Rebellion
uh I'm level 22.
now now I'm only trying to help
what's happening
what is it doesn't cooperate won't you
Leviosa
got him
will never believe this
you can put on story mode get the BC Zoo
yeah I just didn't think to use Leviosa
um I mean there's no offense but how do
you have a round of ideas for Wizarding
World Theory videos I think every time I
sit down to write a script
I think of more than one script to
create so I mean it's the list just
keeps growing so right now my list of
ideas like legitimate ideas that I could
you know actually make it would be
interesting is about
600 videos long so I'm not going to run
out anytime soon
do I ever get burnt out
um
I used to because I used to do a video
every day and that was too much so I
stopped doing that and now I do them
every two days which is
comfortable
but I did every day almost every day for
the first like year and a half two years
where is this sending me
is this for the toad
that's what I'm trying to do
um it's 12 20 in the morning for me
yeah every day was too much
but I have someone that helps me now
with the editing and I have someone uh
that just just taking the editing off my
plate to some extent was really helpful
it allows me to focus on the scripts
more
are these giant purple toads hard to
catch
I don't even know what these things look
like
320 for you
I go to bed quite late
what is this place
that wasn't it
so I just managed to use all the wrong
spells
don't ask me how
oh my God videos
no need to be difficult I mean you know
home
Simon's what's been one of my favorite
videos to make or research prep for
um
I don't know
that's a tough question uh
I did a few recently that I was quite
proud of uh what what can I think of
here hold on
I really enjoyed making the
um is Hogwarts Legacy Canon video and
kind of ranking Canon that was fun uh
uh what else did I do
oh I did one on uh religion which
required quite a lot of research which I
enjoyed doing I did one on the origins
of magic where magic comes from
um I did one on the origins of wizard
kind kind of like
the most interesting topics the ones we
have to dig deep and
really sort of scrounge for information
those are my favorite videos to make
jar jar so powerful he can cast rocks
behind him without looking I know
confidence is growing makes us proud
thank you
so is the quest done is that it
is
thank you
I haven't used incendio in ages
hi Wyatt welcome
incendio's top if I like incendio
but I do love lifting them into the air
as well
let's get this Waypoint
revelio
who's this
what is it what's wrong goblins that's
what Red Rock slot nasty I need a little
something something
you can't defend yourself you'll be
sorry
should I take this question I guess
I have sight the world's not safe at the
moment oh I will Round Rock's lot won't
do I get anything for that
what is it Goblin I just give him a
potion and then nothing
creature I need a little something
I don't have any of
started
it was a waste
he didn't deserve that
I can't believe I thought Harry belonged
with Hermione
not in the film and the book
[Music]
there's so much we don't know about
beasts so much time
[Music]
cough
foreign
this kind of it kind of makes more sense
I completed your assignment professor
I'm ready to learn bombardo now good now
this spell comes with a caveat it's the
exploding charm
I will Professor now you must
remember the exploding charm is highly
volatile
yeah like the scene in the tent when
they dance like that's well done now
in for practice shall we go ahead and
try it on
excellent one work
just like that every time the source and
in control
I did a video on why Wizards don't use
guns
not as effective as you might think
uh I think I'm done for the night guys
um but thank you to everyone who tuned
in
and thank you for everyone who's uh
returning true sighted I'm looking at
you
I'll try and come back soon
um I think probably not tomorrow night
but the night after I'll I'll come on
I hope everyone has a good night thanks
again for watching
foreign